pat riley was the last one in miami to
assemble the big three down there
with a true recruiting focus he went in
and sold him and pitched him but he had
to get wade to recommit
and then he got lebron and bosh to join
but now
it's much more player to player driven
lebron bringing anthony davis
that was the key to transitioning the
lakers from worst to first
we think lebron's getting paid what he's
worth the short answer is for sure
lebron is underpaid
i would agree i personally hate the fact
that you can celebrate a long-term
extension you feel like you got him
locked up you make this
incredible financial commitment and then
he can james harden his way out of here
in a year or two
and it's a disturbing trend in the nba
for sure
could jordan do what lebron is doing
today to the league
back in their era lebron could disrupt
things and
impact business for a little bit but the
league will go on
lebron has been different because
wherever he's gone
it has followed you know jordan was in
one place and all came to him
[Music]
so my guest today is a former lawyer
former executive former president
of the lafc and former general manager
and my
favorite guy to watch on espn
when he would analyze who should go to
what team with the salary cap and i
would be glued
him doing all the stuff that he would do
now we've established a relationship
together and i just wanted to have him
on
valuetainment as a guest so tom thank
you so much for being a guest on
valuetainment
my pleasure good to see you man you look
good good to see you i told you i'm
trying to look like a gm today i look
like a gm
and you look like the agent of one of
the players
[Laughter]
well you know hey i'll take whatever i
can get
so question for you how do you go from a
criminal defense attorney
handling cases including murder armed
robbery and other serious felonies
to wanting to become a gm how does an
attorney go to wanting to become a gm
and an executive that's when you start
wanting to become a gm
and you go do what you can do first
that's what happened there right that
makes sense
yeah i was in law school and knew i
didn't want to go work for a big law
firm i did that in the summers
and so i wanted to do something sports
related
and i just struck out man i tried
everything i went to the nba
primarily that was my interest in uh
still have the box of rejection letters
upstairs in my uh
attic space and uh you know it was back
when you sent a real letter and got a
real letter in return
and then i went to work as a criminal
defense lawyer i went to work with my
dad
he was a really accomplished criminal
defense attorney
and i took a position as a part-time
public defender and that gave me a
caseload of like four cases
every week wow four cases set for trial
you just sort of rolled through it and i
ended up 20 plus jury trials and yeah
stuff is interesting as uh
first degree murder and you know got not
guilties in that which was a crazy
experience and
really everything in between uh
and then segued into being an agent and
then eventually got lucky and found my
way into the nba
now is your dad's temperament like yours
are you guys are you similar than
temperament or no
yeah we were very similar he was a
terrific orator
in his day and just a a total stud
as a criminal defense attorney he really
had a presence and was
was quite a name and that was
interesting for me because i came in
with the exact same
name he's thomas j penn jr
and i'm thomas penn iii right so i came
in not only
in his shadow or adjacent to him i had
the exact same name
so they kind of called me the third
around there which was odd because you
know i never been
known as that but it was the best years
man and
i went to do it for two years and
patrick i did it for six i worked side
by side with my dad
you know we tried cases together he gave
me the flexibility to build
my sports start uh by pursuing
becoming an agent and you know just
being entrepreneurial in spirit but
having the
safety net of a good career in my core
business there
and it was a lot of fun man it was
really cool let me ask you what helped
you out
in transitioning from being a criminal
defense attorney
six years that's not a short period
that's a long time
what helped you out from there to being
an agent
to be in a gm or a system gm working
with jerry west or president
lafc what strength did this give you to
you know
go into these other jobs that you had
well i went to law school just to have
the core
education not knowing what it would lead
to it was either mba or law school my
only regret maybe was not
doing an mba while i was there but i
felt like having the law degree
gave a basis for whatever happened and i
was more drawn to business but first
starting in criminal defense
you know that is like there's nothing
like being
on trial and representing somebody
sitting right next to you with his
or her life on the line and you're
having to perform in front of a jury
live it's kind of like coaching a game
right you know there's a timetable
there's decisions you have to make
you have to express yourself clearly and
you have to persuade
so all those sorts of skills were being
honed
at that part of my career and you got to
work your tail off and be prepared you
know so you're prepared
you're timely you got to make these
decisions on trial and then be
persuasive
so all that kind of wraps together to
uh take you to the next level or take me
to the next
the next level of my career as far as
the transition to sports the advantage
for me was i had the time
to try to make that happen so two of
those six years i was solely focused on
just trying cases winning building that
kind of business
learning two years goes by like that
then i got into a two-year run where i
was trying to build the sports business
and i had the flexibility to do that to
fail it took me an
extra year to do what i wanted to do in
the first six months which was get a
sponsor to sponsor a trip over to europe
so i had enough time to do all that and
then
ultimately come out of it on the other
side to be prepared to jump to the nba
is the sponsor was that upper deck that
sponsored you to go here
how did you do that how did you get
upper deck to sponsor you research i
liked that yeah we were the upper deck
all-stars it was a group of
uh free agents from mostly the chicago
area
and i just banged on a bunch of doors i
mean i just kept
it was title sponsorship of the team and
the tour
and that was when the internet was
coming online and websites and
i had like this little 3d virtual
experience in an arena because
i had a cousin who could build those
sorts of models it was totally
like a side thing so i just threw all
that at a sponsor to see what they liked
and ended up finding my way to upper
deck trading card company and they had a
a guy named yoss boss i'll never forget
him over in amsterdam and he had budget
he was looking to extend outside of
football
into basketball and i found my way in
front of him and he had a little budget
so we became the upper deck all-stars
and did
two tours and that's what made it all
work because i couldn't
afford to underwrite it myself any any
crazy players
at the time that you were working with
no nobody anybody would know a few of
them went on to the nba
one was a guy named donald white's side
who was a very good talented point guard
who ended up playing for the toronto
raptors and is now a coach
and a couple other players most of which
ended up earning a living
in europe and i was just trying to kind
of get things started and
and learn the business and and over the
course of that period of time i also
read the collective bargaining agreement
in the nba
and and i got educated on how those
rules worked and i could talk that talk
a little bit
so i had that basis of information
i read it cover to cover and i outlined
it like a law school
textbook how big is it i mean how
technical is it
um you know it's all legalese and it's
legal jargon right
and then it's written in collective
bargaining form so i don't know it was
three or four hundred pages
but written in an outline form you know
with
and it was just having a legal
background makes it easier because
that's a document constructed by lawyers
for lawyers and then they take that and
condense it to a
20-page memo that they do now that's
pretty good it's easier to understand
but you still get kind of crossed up and
you really don't get that until you get
in and start
doing that work which is what happened
with me at the grizzlies
but i had a fundamental understanding i
had sort of done enough work that i had
something to offer
and i i often say that to people it's
like look
you may not be where you're going but
you should angle towards it you should
prepare for it you should do stuff on
your own to be
educated in that area so when whatever
you're looking for the universe presents
it to you you can respond
did you ever become an agent in the
states in nba or no you went to straight
being an assistant general manager
i was a registered agent in the states
so you had to go through the players
association
you know you pay a pretty strong fee at
the time and you get officially
registered so i do have my little card
still where i was an agent although i
never really built that business to
where i was an
active nba agent with clients you know i
did a few
small deals here and there but it was
nothing significant at all
and i then was in that business long
enough to know
i didn't really want to be an agent
one of my best players that i had the
biggest success story
out of nowhere he just fired me and that
happens to every agent but i got the
letter
by fedex and it kind of broke my heart
and
you know that was one of those things
where it's like wow this is a very
transactional vehicle just get burnt and
then funny postscript on that
my daughter is a freshman volleyball
player at boston college right
and she pieces it together there's this
teammate of hers
from illinois and it's that player's
daughter
get out of here yeah they understand
that's classic so i met your daughter
last time when you and i were speaking
she was there she was visiting from
boston
or something she was she was at the
house she came in and said hi
very interesting so so the agent part
uh is it is it one of those things where
that's the 80 20 rule and the one
percent make
it and 80 get flushed out as agents and
only 20
stick around and out of the 20 you have
one like a rich paul that's pretty much
got a monopoly in the league
is that pretty common on how it works or
no
yeah i mean historically there's just a
small
handful of power agents that control the
market
because so much of that is who else do
you represent
and those players and families get drawn
to those big
power agents so the rich you mentioned
rich paul
you know back in the day with david falk
and arn
teller gordon yep you know those sorts
of agents they would just be this
gravitational pull for all the real
talent
i was just on the periphery and i was
drawn to
europe as an opportunity because there
was more room to just hustle
and make things work and grow and evolve
cracking into the true nba market was
really hard
because uh there's so few of those
talented players every year only 30 get
drafted in the first round right
so they're not hard to identify and all
the power agents of course are on them
you know from day one and what's the
comp on it is the comp
10 or is it what is the number on it so
back then the comp in europe would be 10
of the contract up front paid by the
team
to the age up front so you'd get it up
front so if a guy signed for a hundred
thousand dollars you get ten thousand up
front
right in the nba if a guy signs for a
hundred thousand
it's not that let's make it 100 million
um
the most you could get is four percent
and then that gets negotiated down
by competition and then that's paid over
time by the player
as he gets paid so it's just a
it's a more difficult situation if
you're trying to start out there because
you've got a
it's not a lot of money it it's well
it's become a lot of money
on these bigger deals but with smaller
deals it's not a lot of money and then
you end up you're trying to collect it
from your own player your own talent
over time every two weeks it's just a
challenge yeah but even if i sign a five
year 100 million dollar contract you get
four percent
let's just say they push it down to two
million two and a half percent so it's
two and a half million i'm making
on on 100 million and i'm not gonna get
paid that over a five-year period so
it's really 500 000
your income over a five-year period
that's not that crazy of a number
right yeah and that's if as and when you
get it right
so and at any point the player can
fire you are you still committed to
getting that contract that you got
or how does that work out as an agent
uh if you got him the full 10 million
dollar deal and he fired you the day
after you got it you're still entitled
to it okay good
so at least the agent is protected
legally you are but then you got to go
chase it
you know so then you're if you just play
that out a little bit if you're
getting fired by a player in the in
who's in the club and then you
get in a fight with them to try to go
collect what you legally do
but then your reputation gets hurt it's
just a it's a
it's a tough business for sure
um and as i say i i realized i wasn't
meant for it made for it didn't want to
do that but what it gave me was
an avenue to become active in the sports
world and then relevant if something
else came along which it did
and and and for you becoming a gm i mean
assistant gm at first with
jerry west for those seven years which
jerry west to me
he's just a qualified genius who is who
he is when the when the lakers lost him
there's a couple people when the lakers
lost that i was concerned one of them
was him
the other one was cup check i don't know
why i kind of like cupcake style and i
also like
jerry style what was it like working
with jerry for those seven years at
memphis grizzlies
yeah the the the path in was through
vancouver
right we bought the vancouver grizzlies
and then we moved him to memphis so
there were two years without jerry and
then
five with jerry jerry then came into
memphis as the
president of basketball and
it was amazing i mean at that time
patrick that was you play that game
where you're like who would you want to
have lunch with if there was anybody you
could have lunch with and people would
say oprah or you know lately
you'd say obama whatever it would be in
my
window there my answer was jerry west
because i wanted to
learn something that was relevant to
what i wanted well all of a sudden he
was
his office was like four feet from mine
and his door is always open and he was
an open book right he just would
would uh allow and ask for help and we
worked very closely together with it
with a team of people and it was just
unbelievable quite the experience and uh
you know a lot of fun to work with um
he had true stardust sprinkled on him
still at that age he he you know did
what was interesting with jerry was to
see grown men
in their 60s just like fan girl out on
him when they'd see him at a restaurant
because they had seen him for you know
40 or 50 years they had this familiarity
with him as he
you know he's one of those rare athletes
that transformed himself into being
just as successful in the second phase
in a different way right so i never knew
him as a player i just knew him as this
iconic executive sort of what you're
reacting to
but jerry uh was a is a special person
you know
totally unique and was a lot of fun
working with him what was his recruiting
style i mean there's different ways guys
recruit i i've
kind of watched him closely to see how
he recruited i watched how cupchick
recruited dwight howard he brought him
in took him in one of the rooms he says
look at the rafters look who's up there
the big man
kareem will shaq one day it's gonna say
howard there and then
you know you kind of saw that didn't
work out with howard's personality
because he didn't want that kind of
pressure to be compared to the shadows
of the guys what was jerry's style of
recruiting
well we were recruiting a different
caliber of athlete we were doing a build
from you know one of the worst teams in
the league so in a way it was drafting
talent and then retaining talent and
then
getting guys on the just getting talent
at any level but it wasn't
those kinds of superstars where you're
recruiting it was more
let's get this guy to come let's
identify let's trade for him
a lot of those conversations happen very
directly with agents so
that was where it was a you know i
mentioned arntellum
as an example so aaron was a very close
friend of jerry's
rn representing kobe bryant and a number
of the other
key acquisitions through the years for
the lakers
and they were i was surprised at just
how close
they were uh personally you know i
always
envision that that'd be more of a
contentious relationship and yeah we
hate agents and this and that but what
you learned what i learned from jerry
was just the importance of deep
long-standing relationships
with the power agents because so many of
those guys control
so much of the talent and they can
really help fulfill what you're trying
to accomplish so
that was part of the art part of the
science of
what you'd call recruiting or talent
procurement in the nba
so he was a relationship salesman so he
sold through having strong relationships
with
agents because if he got the agents he
got the player so
it's half the battle of recruiting
players
and having a good relationship with
players through
the agent how much of it is the agent
how much of it is the family how much of
it is the wife how much of it is the
parents how much of it is the player
or does it vary player by player well
it's changed
um it was a little more agent driven
back then
and in the modern era i think it's a
little more peer
and player to player driven so you see
more and more the way that
lebron is a player combined with
maverick carter and his agency that
lebron is an owner of they're able to
assemble the
current lakers roster in a way where
they're doing a lot of maneuvering and
manipulating
and the straight-up recruiting you know
the
the straight-up recruiting is
technically illegal
if it comes from any member of an other
team that's tampering
you can't tamper with current players on
other rosters
well a loophole in that has been player
to player where the players
we can't restrict what they do or say to
each other
so over the last 10 years or so that's
really taken form
you know even going back to pat riley
was the last one in miami to really
assemble the big three down there with a
true recruiting focus he went in and
sold him and pitched him he had weighed
but he had to get wade to recommit
and then he got lebron and bosh to join
but the the other secret of that success
was he got them all to take like 5
million less than they should have taken
that's right
18 million 19 million 16 million i don't
remember the number and i think
even bosch was getting the most money
out of the three right so they all took
a haircut of 5 million that freed up 15
million a year to go get
the next three you know the mike millers
of the world the way that
all murders are out and really gave him
the
the finals championship caliber every
year so
um but now it's much more you know james
harden
goes to be with durant and goes to be
with kyrie because there's direct
conversations happening as part of that
whole exchange
uh you know when chris paul moves or
maneuvers he's
talking direct with whoever he's going
to be playing with and of course lebron
bringing anthony davis
represented by that same group you know
that was the core the key to
transitioning the lakers from worst to
first
you think this is sustainable long-term
because you know if you think about
how the league was back in the days take
michael
okay so if you go era michael
and then go prior era let's say you know
well i can't really say well let's just
say bird magic
because they came in uh when they came
in so michael
then kobe shack and then you got lebron
today
when magic and bird were running versus
michael versus lebron and
kobien today
could magic and bird or even jordan do
what lebron is doing today to the league
back in their era
which aspect of it the fact that i mean
you you
if you were if i were to say to you
right now
who is the most powerful figure in the
nba
it's lebron right he has the most power
that nobody has more power in dmb than
lebron he still keeps it now his job is
to stay healthy
relevant do the things that he does and
he's a visionary
he's going to do big things so he's
doing his part but he's the most
powerful guy
but if i told you in 2000
the most powerful person in the nba
would you have said
kobe or would you have said a different
name and if i was to tell you let's go
into 1991
when jordan won his first would you have
said the most powerful person in the nba
is michael or would it be jerry buss
would it have been
another jerry or because it's changing
based on who has the most power
well i'd say first in any era right
there is the commissioner
i mean the commissioner in each of those
cases has tremendous power
and because the commissioner represents
the
combined true power and of the ownership
right so they will last
past any player even today oh yeah i
mean if lebron
lebron couldn't take the league down
lebron could
disrupt things and impact business for a
little bit but the league will go on
right and the the sure of course
but when you get into the most i would
have said jordan i mean back in the day
as i
reflect on it in the in the early 90s
when jordan was
in his heyday he was
you know massively uh influential
powerful
and you know global and
but he wasn't and they and he he was the
draw
because he and pippin were such a solid
base they're able to
flip all the other pieces around them
and dominate and win
six effectively six in a row because
jordan was gone for two of them
um so he was that dominant as a talent
and as a draw
lebron is it has been different because
he's
wherever he's gone it has followed which
is different
you know jordan was in one place and it
all came to him
this notion of lebron just going
from cleveland to miami four straight in
the finals goes right back to cleveland
where they were literally the worst and
they get to first
and they go to the finals it was you
know it's just incredible yeah
then he does the same thing coming out
here to la
albeit it took a year um
that shows the i don't know if back in
that era jordan could have done that
because it was a different time you know
they're just people wouldn't have been
able to come with them the way they do
now
yeah and also i mean david stern was a
different animal david stern was a
uh uh uh he was feared and respected it
was a different uh uh
way and i'm not saying adam silver
doesn't have that kind of a personality
but adam silver comes across very
different
than stern did i just don't know
if if lebron was to be playing in the
80s or 90s
could he have gone around and told
everybody hey if it's not working out
with the owner leave the team hey if
it's not working out with the owner
leave the team like right now
players are just coming out and saying
look i don't like playing with the team
i'm leaving hey anthony davis i don't
want to be with the pelicans i'm leaving
so
if i'm a small market and if i'm getting
ready to spend 2 billion
to buy a team say two to three billion
dollars to buy any team in the nba today
if i'm if i'm a small market what makes
michael think he's gonna be able to keep
lamella ball for more than seven years
before he goes to celtics or he goes to
miami or he goes to the lakers or
you know what makes milwaukee think they
can keep giannis for another
four years yeah they just signed a
contract but almost the smaller markets
are being bullied more today
but maybe it's been the same for decades
you're in it what are your thoughts on
it now that's changed i mean i i
personally
hate this i hate the fact that you can
celebrate a long-term extension
your honest example is a perfect one you
know you feel like you got them locked
up you make these
incredible financial commitment all
fully guaranteed the second he signs it
no matter what
and then he can james harden his way out
of here in a year or two i mean hardin
just did it in houston as soon as it got
unpleasant as soon as they weren't
consulting him on every move or whatever
you know it just
he became crabby
cantankerous and just and
bogarted is way right out of his deal
and you know
undercuts the trade value on his way out
because everybody in the league knows
what the deal is
and it's it's a it's a disturbing trend
in the nba
for sure yeah you know all it does to me
is i wonder let's just say if i'm
about about to own a sports team would i
buy a small market or buy into a small
market
not in today's league i i would be very
concerned about being a small market in
today's league it would concern the hell
out of me because
because today it's such a player's
market
that players are essentially bullying
everybody it's
it's full-on bullying they are bullying
everybody now don't get me wrong
if we go back in the 80s we could say
jerry the gm was bullying everybody on
the ball so there was an element of that
taking place
so the the happy medium is kind of tough
to be it's almost like we go far one
side it's gm or ownership control then
we go too much of a player's side it's
player
control but we all know that lebron is
eventually going to own a sports team
you know so so how do you manage that
balance the two
between the player and the owners the
reality today i would not want to own a
sports team today if it was in a small
market
sort of depends depends on which league
you're in green bay packers doing okay
right that's the nfl though yeah in the
nfl they're all
profitable because of the way they share
revenues and because of the massive
meteor i agree
so every single team in the nfl is
profitable no matter how bad they screw
it up just look in jacksonville yeah
and then uh in the nba
with more revenue sharing now the
smaller markets have become
and with uh a subsidy from the league
effectively the the smaller markets have
become
much more healthy financially and then
you do have some superstars who have
maintained
a significant presence in a small market
i mean damien lillard right now seems
just fine in portland
giannis is a good example he's resigned
twice
in milwaukee and they're one of the best
teams in the league because of his
extreme talent
and then of course you had the success
of the spurs for decades
in one of the smallest markets in the
league and the utah jazz right now are
pretty darn good in a small market and
so on and so forth so
all those rules in the league tend to
give those small markets
a fighting chance except baseball you
know that's where it's still just wacky
so let me ask you this having been
around jerry and haven't been around a
lot of different guys then does that
mean
is the best when when you're when you're
putting a team together
what is your number one is your number
one putting a coach like pop together
that's going to keep the players for a
while
or is the number one getting a good gm
is the number one getting the superstar
like giannis
what is the number one to keep not
necessarily the golden handcuffs but to
be able to get
a team that's willing to be in a market
like san antonio
which you know it's not necessarily the
craziest outside of the three river
stadium and the alamo you got nothing
really going on over there
i'm starting from day one i want the
best player because you need the best
player
to establish any kind of competitiveness
and greatness but if i want to
start from scratch with this notion of
what's most
important most important is committed
ownership
so you need deep pocketed passionate
ownership that's in it for the right
reason because over time that's what
sustains things and wins
and you want a good head on that guy's
shoulders or gal whoever that owner is
somebody that will then go hire good
management
so in your san antonio spurs example
you had solid ownership that just got
popovich and rc buford as this
incredible tandem to lead basketball
operations and to maintain
this incredible level of success over
the years in spite of being in a small
market it was just you know 20 years of
exceptional work there but
there's no question it's a talent game
so in that scenario
if you're if you're giving me for one
year the best owner the best coach or
the best player i'll take the best
player
who's the second second in that show
go with that do your draft best owner
best gm best player best coach your
first best player what second
if it's for one year it's the best coach
because he's going to have the most
influence on performance
okay give me if you want to build a
legacy like if you want to build a 10
year run
so if you're first as player what's your
second
well if it's a 10-year run i
i it's still best owner you got to have
the best owner to give you the chance to
make all those maneuvers and you know
and to do all that then you got to have
great management
you know just build it got it okay got
it
so you're going you're going owner gm
coach player
honor gm player coach owner okay
got it interesting owner gm
player coach and why is coach last for
you
because the coach is only as good as his
players
i mean you know the great coaches pick
the great talent to go coach
that's how it works um
yes there's this theory that you get an
amazing coach and he's going to max out
whatever talent he has but that's only
within a
a small band of a small percentage if
you put
greg popovich with the worst talent in
the league
he may win them five more games
so they go from 15 wins to 20 or 22
but he can't take a 15 15-win talent to
make get it to
500. i wonder if he sees this if he'll
be offended by that if he'll say come on
you know i'd take him into the playoffs
even if he gave me a bunch of scrubs
i'm sure he would agree with you on that
but so if that's the case who would you
put right now as the best coaches in the
nba
um best coaches in the nba
well pop is still you know over time as
good as it gets
just a master what i look for in a coach
is a master relationship expert
and a tactician you know and a
competitor
and everything that goes with that and
greg popovich is just truly amazing
um eric spoelstra has quietly
done just a remarkable job over the
years down in miami
uh you know a great guy a very
incredibly heart a credible hard worker
managed that
unusual transition to come in
and succeed pat riley who's one of the
biggest personalities and
most respected just nba studs you know
just a
he's patch revered by so many folks for
what he's done in so many different
places and just kind of who he is
um and uh spellstr has just done a
remarkable job of uh
navigating through all that so you put
spellstr a second
behind uh interesting well i don't know
my list in front of me there are plenty
of others he just jumped into my head
yeah i mean listen it's respect because
even if you think about it who the hell
thought last year miami was going to go
to the finals and let alone win a couple
you know nobody thought they were going
to go that far and that's a lot of
credit for spoelstra
so here's the other question about the
nba kirsten know what you'll say about
this
is is lebron getting paid what he's
worth this is how i kind of process it
and maybe i'm wrong hear me out these
guaranteed contracts
i'm not a fan of however i also don't
think the players are getting paid
accordingly and this is what i mean by i
am much
for like lebron right now is making what
39.6 i don't know the exact number he's
making what
219 okay curry's making 43.
you got westbrook making what he's
making with 41. you got four people at
41 westbrook paul hardin and wall
durant's at 40 and then you got lebron
at 39. okay
there's no way in the world lebron's
worth 39 okay
uh lebron is you know when you got a
messi and some of the other soccer
players making what they're making i get
it that
soccer's got more viewership it's more
international it's more
bigger than the nba and nba is trying to
kind of do that
but when a lebron comes to your market
listen everybody makes more money in
that community when lebron comes to your
market
so is a player like him where he is the
face of the nba
you know michael last year i don't know
what he got paid his last year 30
million or some
astronomical number that he got paid and
most of his career he got underpaid
we think lebron's getting paid what he's
worth right now you think it's closer to
an 80 to 100 million dollar year player
i'd say more than that i would agree
messi is more than that
and while global
football you're right the economics are
different but
those you know barcelona doesn't make
money they're in debt
and that's because they can't lose a guy
like messi so they go
you know figure it out uh
you know the maximum salary
the short answer is for sure lebron is
underpaid not just because he's at 39
and other guys are at 41 or 42
it's because he should be more like 100
let's say right i agree
yeah but the reason that happens is
because of collective bargaining
because there's a economic system in
place designed
to make all the boats rise and to make
all those teams be competitive
so the players get together and
collectively bargain for these
totally anti-american things i mean in
no other industry can
some arbitrary system decide where you
can go work via the draft
right but they agree to do that totally
un-american
the whole restricted free agency you
can't leave our team unless we get a
chance to pay you
just as much well there's no other
industry where that makes sense
collective bargaining
maximum salary we're gonna put a firm
cap
on the most money any player can make
well there's a minimum salary
right so you know they're all making
about a million bucks now
so those are the trade-offs that occur
and lebron as a superstar
absolutely got squeezed and gets
squeezed by having
that maximum keep his value down
got it so he is essentially
helping a lot of the lower level players
that would typically be a quarter
million dollar year player or four
hundred thousand dollar play he put him
at a million
so when his comp went lower they went
theirs went a little higher
if if if i pull off a kyrie irving and i
say guys i don't feel like working the
next two weeks does the team still have
to pay him or no
no well if the player flat refuses to
show up in work
he gets suspect you know there's there's
progressive discipline that occurs but
including suspension you don't pay
but these trade-offs that occur now more
and more
with the resting healthy guys just for
the sake of
managing their minutes and you know this
this latest era
of nobody plays 82 games anymore because
they're gonna arrest them
you know that's that slippery slope
where you continue to pay guys to not
work
and the league has tried to shut that
down because you know
we're all paying what we're paying if
we're allowed to go to a game
we as fans are paying that ticket price
to go seat the talent
and then it just doesn't show up they're
trying to rectify that
yeah so the solution for that if i was
running a comp plan is i would
overpay a lebron to 100 million a year
plan
but if a guy didn't play you ain't
getting paid either so so it would be
hey kyra you want to take nine games off
no problem you're 31 million divided by
82 games
you just lost 31 million divided by 82
games times
nine games that you missed just because
you don't want to show up
it's easy with specific examples but in
collective bargaining they just set the
rules
i'm sure they do i i'm sure you've got a
union watching out for every kyrie
irving
so that it doesn't happen together
totally get it totally you add a union
to anything these types of things happen
i just think a guy like lebron
a guy like lebron who brings whatever he
brings to the market he's not a 40
million auto guy that's a 80 200 million
dollar guy if not higher
now look the argument would be that the
system is so healthy and has worked so
well and it's such a healthy league
that lebron's able to beat lebron
on the rest of the stage and earn
everything else that comes with it
so that'd be the the overall argument as
far as
how that a healthy nba gives the
platform
for lebron to be lebron i mean i don't
own a team in the nba yet so but if i
did
i would say hey guys why don't we also
protect the owners a little bit and
protect the players we'll play a little
bit more
but also at the same time you know we
also want to be protected on this end
and uh who knows how those conversations
go you know you got to be careful with
these lawyers tom i mean these lawyers
just
very interesting people these lawyers
are that's right
exactly right so now you go to la lafc
so you've done what you've done in the
mba you go become an analyst at the uh
uh
espn you know you refused to take a
position as a gm with 76ers and by the
way what year was that when you said you
don't want the gm position at 76ers
[Laughter]
i'm not sure it went down exactly like
that but uh
what year was that around 2013 maybe
i don't know
when did embiid get uh picked what was
the year embiid got picked uh way later
yeah way later got it okay so 2013 who
was there in 2012 2013 who's their best
player ai
igodawa now doug collins was the coach
elton brand was playing
sorry i can't remember 2012 76ers wasn't
andre igor that one
uh yeah iguodala was there yeah
yeah i'm curious now who it was okay
so you you you decided to go play uh uh
larry allen elton brand yeah elton brand
drew holiday andre iguodawa
uh uh interesting squad lou williams
yeah
but that was yeah that was a period of
time where uh i interviewed with them
was you know went through the whole
process uh didn't
didn't happen didn't work out and you
know just why didn't you want to be a
gym what what what
moving forward at that time i kind of
did want to be a gm it was just a matter
of finding the right fit
got it look i i had done this sports
summit in aspen that brought together
sports owners from around the world
and then we did other best practice
summits for college athletic directors
for
sports management so that got me out of
the silo
of being in basketball operations and
being a gm
and it sort of broadened my entire
look into other sports and into other
jobs you know being the president of a
team for example
and then from that ecosystem in aspen
with the sports owners
came the investors for lafc and we were
able to
put together a really compelling group
to come to los
angeles and get a major league expansion
team
and the chance to build a whole
club from nothing you know it was just
in in october of 2014 we were an idea
and the lafc lafc.com was available and
we went and snuck out and bought it
and we decided we'd kick off with that
identity
and then you know everything happened
from there where we just basically
you know created the whole thing out of
nothing it was funny that was a sick
experience i bet i mean you were the
president
you were president of it for how long
five or six years you
yeah six so yeah i was the sort of first
person hired
but we had been in pursuit of the team
so we had put together the group to
acquire
the team and so i had assembled the
ownership group
along with uh henry nguyen was an
investor from vietnam who came in
initially and then peter guber
who owns the warriors and the dodgers
and is an iconic
hollywood figure was big in music
and giant in film chairman of sony and
then he's reinvented himself as just a a
really really well respected sports
owner
so peter became our executive chairman
and was this linchpin
partner that made the whole thing work
and we were awarded the
expansion franchise in major league
soccer and
you know had made a financial commitment
to build a brand new stadium
and there hadn't been an outdoor stadium
built in los angeles since
dodger stadium in 1962 so
it wasn't an easy thing to do but we
were able to incrementally do it we
built bank california stadium which is
just this
absolutely spectacular venue right in
the heart of the city
uh really an unbelievable experience you
know one of the
i say it's the best fan experience in
sports
in in in america it's just an incredible
experience because the fans
sing the entire time it's this just
joyous super passionate atmosphere that
you don't find
even in college college football is
similar
with the band and the rhythm of a
student section but
the lafc game is like amazing because
it's just so organic and you got regular
people
coming together singing and cheering and
drinking beer and throwing beer when we
score goals it's cool
how big do you think it's gonna how big
you think soccer is gonna get in the u.s
you think it's eventually gonna get to
the point where
we'll win a world cup in the next decade
two decades three decades what do you
think
uh those are two separate questions so
that the the part about
winning the world cup is a tactical
question
about whether we can get a pipeline
and a system of talent development
that's on par with what's in the rest of
the world
our competitive advantage in a way is
we're such a big country with so much
talent
our disadvantage is we're such a big
country
with so much other opportunity and it's
really hard to
train players in los angeles the way
they'll train in texas the way they'll
train in
the philadelphia new york area for
example those are just those are like
separate countries when it comes to
the whole approach the whole ethos of
the way
you know the ideology whereas germany
and they were able to come up with their
whole system
and then just take all the talent put it
into that one sport
and build it into that juggernaut that
the german national team became
i don't know if we can do that there's a
lot of effort and conversation around it
and as soon as we start getting our best
athletes
physical athletes drawn to that sport
where they can stay in that sport that's
what's important with mls's development
is there's now a
clear professional path forward in that
sport that can be appealing where they
can make money
and that hasn't been there for
generations so
that's as it relates to the national
team as it relates to just the
trajectory of the sport
in general i don't know that it eclipses
something like
american football or the nba but there's
a lot of room for it to grow
and the media attention can be massive
in america
and then there's no other global sport
i mean let's not fool ourselves the nba
is not anywhere
near football global football when it
comes to relevance
i mean you know that it's just true but
i always thought the nba was global
being in soccer there's nothing like it
yeah it's craziness with soccer it's a
whole different story and
and carlos villa i just pulled up his
salary 2018 four and a half million
dollars
uh uh what he was making so some of
these guys starting to make some checks
which is good for the younger guys
would would in this case would it be the
same as building a 10 10-year legacy on
a team meaning you need a good owner
then you need the right gm then you need
a player then you need the right coach
what would need to happen for america to
commit to winning a
you know world cup do we need to go
recruit the biggest best coaches and
trainers and bring them
in and teach other coaches in the u.s
how to coach other kids so all of a
sudden there's a
90-day camp of coaches in us from texas
from
philadelphia from florida from
california come go through camp of how
to train their guys how would you build
that up in america
well i don't have that answer or we
would have done it you know they've
tried different things in america those
are different things so
with a national team it's a different
experience that
it's a they're never together for 90
days
maybe if they're at a world cup and they
go the whole way so
you get the best talent you bring them
together for
in windows of like one two
and four weeks or maybe for a long
summer competition it's six weeks it's
just and then
they continue to play on their
professional teams the whole time so
they just take a break
in the soccer schedule the best players
go play for their national teams for two
weeks and then they come back
and they keep going and they play year
round so
it's a different coaching challenge
so the us went out and got jurgen
klinsmann
who from the german national team from
that way of life
thinking they could replicate that way
and that didn't work they've had
homegrown coaches like bob bradley who's
the coach at lafc he had a ton of
success
in building uh a team that went well but
then that ended quickly right so it's
just
it's a different it's a completely
different animal and if i had an answer
to your question as to how to
systematize the nation our nation with
our size and our challenges
i'd be in a different role making a lot
more money
i'd be curious you know what country use
the model that worked that they went
from nobody to somebody that's what i'd
be curious about because
when you typically think about it who do
you think about you think about
brazil you think about argentina you
think about germany i was in germany in
1990 when they wanted you think about
france italy
you think about some of these guys but
how about the country that was
irrelevant that came and won and how did
they do it i'd be curious to know what
their model was
but you know beckham obviously came and
he played which was big when he came out
and zlatan came out and i went and
watched zlatan played
it was ridiculous watching how folks in
la were reacting to zlatan playing
and the whole controversy between zlatan
and vey i think that was needed for the
mls believe it or not i think there's
some kind of a
animosity you need somebody like that do
you think a messi
or ronaldo will eventually play in the
mls i do
i think ronaldo will sunset his career
here
just to transition to the rest of his
life could
i think that's a natural how about messi
i don't know maybe messi's less
interested in all that stuff
messi's more just about
expressing his art playing his tail off
you know being compensated for it
he's less uh diverse dynamic
in terms of his interest level you know
i think last top
last topic before we wrap up you did
some stuff with upper upper deck before
were you ever a baseball card or
basketball card guy you're not really
i wasn't really yeah
you were not well i am i i
recently sold a couple gretzky cards for
two million dollars it was the most
expensive hockey card sold so i've been
in cards for 30 years
and the only reason i brought up cards
is because you got upper deck to sponsor
you
when you're going to europe so maybe you
had a connection with cars
what do you think about these crazy
things going on with cars right now
dirk's car
sold on his birthday for 4.6 million
dollars
it's lunatics like you willing to trade
in this
i don't get it let me ask you
you really sold two gretzky cards for
that kind of money two gretzky cards for
one of them i sold for um one of them i
saw for 1.29 million dollars
and the other one i sold for 720
000 uh yeah it was all over the news and
it was
pretty interesting were those originals
that you had from the beginning or did
you buy them
i bought them for uh i bought them for
540 000 both of them 18 months prior to
me selling it so i bought it for 540
18 months later sold it for 2 million 10
000 wow
interesting yeah the world of cards is a
different card i don't know if you saw
what a guy named beeple just did
last week when he sold an nft are you
familiar with nft market or not really
okay let me put it to you this way this
guy is a graphic designer
okay he designs something new
every day for 5 000 days okay 5 000 days
he makes a collage of it you've not seen
this i'm surprised you've not seen this
he makes a collage of it okay collage of
it
which means take the 5000 pictures and
you turn it into one collage
right he puts it on christie's auction
which you may be familiar with
christie's auction
it's the bigger auction they do the van
goghs they do all the bigger stuff
the auction starts on february 26 with
the first bid out of 100
tom this is a blockchain art you can't
put it up on the wall it's a picture
that you keep
crypto right type of a crypto type of
thing they call it non-fungible
tokens started at 100 february 26th
it sold on march 11th for what do you
think
tell me just i just want you to actually
guess i really want you to guess
give a big number i'm getting 12 million
okay you ready i'm going to show it to
you just to see your reaction
okay it's sold tom this is crazy stuff i
had a conversation with this guy
yesterday
here's what it's sold for you ready
wow 69 million dollars
we are living in a very different era
today
a guy named meta meta coven meta meta
something a guy that's a fan of his
content
and what he creates now you got to
realize this guy named mike winkelmann
is
known in the market he's phenomenal at
what he does
but he you know to sell to sell an art
that you can't hang up anywhere and if
anybody else
shares it you don't make residuals on it
you just get to say you own that token
for 69 million bucks crazy
yeah so you but but for yourself you
went from that into
a completely different business yourself
right you've been doing why don't you
tell everybody what you're doing i know
it's a pretty good size industry and you
guys have been able to get the accounts
for the mba i think uh what is it mba
mls and the dodgers is that what you
have you
yeah so this is a company called
co-protect where we're doing
branded disposable face masks as an
another ppe
so we took the boring blue medical mask
and
commercialized it with all sorts of
fashion on a disposable mask
and yeah the signature stuff in sports
is big we're doing all of march madness
so when you watch any of the games
in the tournament this month uh you're
gonna see all there's 750 000 masks out
there that we did with all sorts of
different designs
the nba major league baseball major
league soccer
team usa uh we've got some big news
coming in global football
you know go down the list bunch of pga
tour events
uh number of big colleges all that sort
of stuff so we've just
dominant in sports we're the leaders in
in branded protective equipment
you know you know 2020 was a 72 billion
dollar industry
yeah it's a pretty big industry you're a
part of well tom it's been a blast
talking to you
appreciate you for coming on obviously a
different direction of a conversation
but
a lot to learn about the business side
of the mba and how a person like you
went from
working with your dad as an attorney to
go to an agent in europe and then from
there going to
working with vancouver memphis and then
a bunch of different experiences in espn
and
mls are now doing what you're doing yeah
cool well great
enjoyed it congrats on all your success
are you going to sell any cards
later today i'm going to probably sell a
lot of cards and i'll tell you about it
if you want to buy a couple i got a few
if you want to buy some
we should talk maybe we'll go in on one
or something i look forward to it we
should we should
tom good talking buddy take care bye bye
for those of you guys that watch the
entire interview i don't know if you
know this or not everything we talked
about in this interview has to do with
business whether it's recruiting
who you get first timing sequencing
money
dollar negotiation career path what
direction you go to people you meet
and how you go from being a guy working
under your father eventually becoming a
president of lafc that magic johnson's
involved welfare all these
peter group all these people are
involved so i hope you stuck around for
the entire thing and if you enjoyed this
interview
and you learned a lot from the business
of the nba you're going to enjoy my
interview i do with stephen a smith
last year if you've not watched it click
click over here to watch the interview
with stephen a
i think if you like this one you will
get a kick out of that as well take care
everybody bye